[Music]
welcome to the view from 22 I'm Ben
Lazarus The Spectators special projects
editor after the air strike on a Garen
hospital last night it appears that the
conflict is going to heat up this week
the Israelis have provided ample
evidence to suggest it wasn't them
although Hamas and and the Arab world
are still insisting that it was an
Israeli air strike joining me to discuss
this and and other aspects of the wildy
conflict is Benny Morris one of Israel's
most eminent living historians Morris is
part of a group of historians who were
term the new historians in Israel uh for
taking a revisionist look at what
preceded 1948 and also the 1948 War
itself uh Morris refused to serve in the
occupied West Bank and was briefly
imprisoned but despite this he's not
universally liked by the left for his
criticism of the Palestinian authorities
and their rejectionism of a two-state
solution so Benny thank you very much
for joining us today my pleasure um I
thought I'd I'd start things by asking
about your views on uh the attack on the
gazen hospital yesterday uh and the air
strike and the sort of subsequent
Fallout that we've seen across the Arab
world well to begin with it seems to me
that the
IDF um produced a convincing evidence
that it was a rocket which was fired by
the Islamic Jihad
and it fell by accident on the hospital
grounds it wasn't the result of an
Israeli Air Attack they checked to the
Air Force no plane was flying at the
time and they have a recording of Hamas
activists saying that where the rocket
came from and there was an Islamic Jihad
rocket but regardless of that how how
much of a flasho moment do you think
this might prove to be within the Arab
world itself I don't think I think it'll
pass um it obviously has enraged the
Arab world because the Arab world
believes the what Hamas says Hamas
always lies and the lies are always
absorbed and accepted by the public um
basically ignorant public in the Arab
world and what do you make of Joe Biden
in uh Israel today and his his comments
what happened at the hospital he seemed
to support um and accept the Israeli
version of what happened um but that I
think this is less important I think the
the war itself is not yet begun the
Israeli offensive against a the northern
part of the Gaza Strip will proceed I
assume in the coming days and this will
be just one event in the chain of events
which began of course with the terrorist
attack by the Hamas in which a thousand
civilians were murdered many in their
beds many children many women raped Etc
and could you see a situation where
Israel ends up fighting a war on two
fronts both in the Gaza Strip and also
on the Lebanon border with
hisbah unfortunately it's a good
possibility um at the moment my
assumption is along with some
commentators that Iran is not interested
in theah in Lebanon joining the war
fully joining the war because Israel
will strike back it'll of course be very
difficult for Israel to fight on two
fronts but theah might lose a lot of its
power much of its Weaponry many of its
people um in such a war with Israel and
I think Iran wants to save theah and its
deterrent effect on Israel um to
preserve protect its nuclear
installations and its nuclear program
that's what they built up theah with
150,000 rockets in their store rooms for
to to deter Israel from attacking the
Iranian nuclear project so I I think
they will want to preserve it but it
could be the pressures from below from
the Arab world from preachers will be
such that theah will gradually join the
war full-fledged and then Israel will
face a twoof front War which will be
very difficult and could you see a
ground invasion of Gaza being a success
in terms of in military terms
well if the aim it depends what the aims
are if the aim is as they originally
said the generals Etc that it is to
destroy utterly destroy the Kamas to
that it sees being a military force and
threat which could again launch such a
strike against Israel in the future if
that's the aim it's going to be a long
hard SLO Israel will do it slowly I
assume house by house neighborhood by
neighborhood in Gaza City and around it
and perhaps later on in the sou southern
part of the strip um Israel will do it
slowly because it'll want not to kill
civilians but it'll also want to
preserve its own troops from dying in
fire fights with Hamas gunman um but I
assume it can be done if Israel has
allowed the months of battle which this
will take Benny You' said before that
the extremists on both sides of of
Israel
Palestine the extreme voices are too
loud too prominent and as a as a result
the moderate voices get drown out after
the potential ground invasion of Gaza
and and once the war heats up even more
is there not a case that the extreme
voices within the Palestinian ranks will
only get more and more
extreme I assume that will happen
certainly in the first period of this
ground Invasion when Israeli tanks and
troops roll into the neighborhoods of
Gaza and a lot of civilians will die in
the process a lot of Hamas gunmen will
die in the the process um but if the
thing is successful if the offensive is
successful my assumption is this will um
strike into the minds and PSY psyches of
um all Palestinians they will understand
that they have they have been made to
pay a terrible price for their attack on
the 7th of October against Israel's
Villages around the Gaza Strip and
perhaps it'll make them even more
moderate but I don't know you're
probably right that these these sort of
things tend to certainly at least
initially a produce more
extremism now but Benny earlier this
year you were um a signatory on a letter
um accusing American Jews of not paying
enough attention to uh Israeli apartheid
and and and ethnic cleansing uh within
Palestine to what extent do you blame
the sort of mistreatment of pal
Palestinians on on what we saw two weeks
ago on October the
7th there is a vital link between theas
offensive and the atrocities it
committed and the history of the
conflict which involved Arabs attacking
Jews initially a massacring Jews in
various places such as kbron in 1929 and
Israelis massacring Arabs in the 1948
war and continues back and forth between
Arab gorilla or terrorist attacks
Palestinian and Israeli retaliation and
counterinsurgency in the schools in the
West Bank and especially under Hamas and
the Gaza Strip um hatred has been taught
to kids from the moment they are born
essentially and they grow up hating Jews
and hating the state of Israel for what
it has done and has done a things to the
Palestinians without of course them
being taught the things the Arabs have
done to the Jews um and um this is um a
product in some way of that can you ever
see that being
resolved unfortunately not I don't see
the way forward the idea of a two-state
solution in my view is unrealistic the
Palestinians have always rejected every
compromise based on two-state Prop
proposals under the British in appeal
commission 1937 the United Nations
General Assembly 1947 Clinton Barack
2000 they've always rejected the idea of
a Jewish State alongside an Arab state
in a partition Palestine um and they
continue essentially in their hearts to
believe the Zionist um Enterprise is a
robber Enterprise and Israel is a robber
State and they refuse to accept its
legitimacy and so long that is that is
their mindset they will not agree to
partitioning Palestine into two states
in addition to that Israel has moved to
the right the Israel settlement
Enterprise has Sprout has
blossomed essentially taking over the
land in the West Bank which would be
part of a Palestinian Arab state were
there to be a two-state settlement what
that means essentially is that the
settlement Enterprise is a major
impediment to Arab acceptance of a two
State settlement were they willing to
countenance an Israeli state in in the
land of Palestine or the land of Israel
so what do you foresee that the status
quo just continues for decades to come
yes and you know you you were always
sort of considered of the left and
you're you're writing on on the original
creation of Israel sort of saw you as a
revisionist historian and and you were
sort of embraced by the left but over
the years you've been quite dismissive
of sort of Palestinian rejectionism of a
two-state solution do you still consider
yourself part of the the
left I would say yes because
theoretically um in terms of I ideas I
think a two-state solution is the only
solution which gives both people a me a
measure of what they desire and a
measure a measure of Justice
um Palestine ruled and governed only by
the Arabs does not give the Jews Justice
a land of Palestine completely dominated
government
by the Jews all of it in Jewish
possession does not give the Arabs a the
Palestinian Arabs a modicum of justice
so I still believe that but but I don't
see any realistic way to get to a
two-state solution given the the
circumstances now Benny you you've
spoken before about how um in many ways
this conflict has now become a sort of
broader Clash of civilizations there is
a clash of civilizations if you like but
it's part of the clash of of
civilizations between the Muslim World
essentially in my view or if you like
the extremist Muslim world but I fear
it's the Muslim World in fact and the
West the values of these two worlds are
completely different and they're
clashing continuously in the streets of
Belgium however where a Muslim yesterday
murdered two swedes because they were
Christians or infidels The Clash in
Palestine is part of it a the Turkish
Muslim destruction of the Christian
minorities 100 years ago is part of it
these are all parts of this Clash of
civilizations and where do you see
Iran's role within that today Iran well
Iran is at the Vanguard of this Muslim
effort to dominate the Middle East and
perhaps even for Islam to take over the
world down the road and they think in
these terms it seems strange in West to
Western ears but they do think that the
Islam is the right religion Allah is the
right God and eventually he will win
over and win over the whole of the world
this this is what they really want this
is what B ladin said this is what they
they desire and Iran is at the Forefront
of this
effort but you don't see Iran entering
the frey in this current round of
conflict I don't know as I said I think
there's a problem for them with if you
like expending or wasting theah on this
effort to protect the Palestinians in
Gaza when in fact Iran wants them to
protect Iran itself and its nuclear
installations as a a sort of a forward a
post um and and um a deterrent Force
against Israel so I I don't know but
it's quite possible Iran will be sucked
in the Americans have sent their some of
their Armed Forces to the area these two
um carriers and some other um units um
toward off the Iranians but should Iran
be sucked in I wouldn't be surprised if
the Iranians um are hit by the Americans
it's also quite possible that if the war
degenerates or expands a to involve
theah as well maybe Israel or the
Americans will use the opportunity to
destroy the Iranian nuclear
installations which it is long targeted
in a sense ideologically that is Iran
says it wants to destroy Israel it's
building an atomic weapon with which it
could do this Israel has always said we
will never allow and so of the Americans
we will never allow the Iranians to have
nuclear weapons because they can't be
trusted with them and they intend to
destroy neighbors um so it's quite
possible this might end up with a um
Israeli or Israeli American um campaign
to destroy the Iranian nuclear
capabilities would you like to see that
happen yes earlier in the discussion you
you you mentioned that that you know
what we're seeing today has sort of very
historical Roots you've done more to
uncover bad things that the zist um
campaigners did in the in the runup to
the 1948 war and including the 1948 49
War um at the same time if you were to
look at hamas's Charter it's obviously a
very explicitly anti-semitic document
how separate are those two things you
know we what's what's more The Guiding
influence for what we're seeing Hamas do
today is it historical injustices or is
it the fact that they simply really do
not like Jews living in Palestine at
all it's probably a combination I
wouldn't I wouldn't know which is it
depends on each person and what's in his
mind but essentially both things
converge if things they see that the
Jews have done which they regard as
nasty and some of which are were nasty
and their ideology which basically
rejected any Jewish presence so
certainly a sovereign presence in pal
Palestine or any part of Palestine um
these things converge in their minds
they're as I say brought up on this
ideology as I think I fear Iranian
children are today um and um this is
basically um sort of a nihilistic
approach to um international relations
um and um it leads to the acts of
terrorism the sorts of terrorism we saw
and the so the CED Behavior by the Hamas
Fighters when they entered the Jewish
settlements on October 7th and if you
were prime minister if you were Benjamin
Netanyahu what would you do in response
to those
attacks well I I wouldn't like to be
benjam he's an awful prime minister a
corrupt politician and should have been
gotten rid of long ago um I think that
he's being forced by the Israeli public
and the security and defense
establishment um to launch this
offensive which I presume will begin in
a few days um because that's essentially
what Israel wants partly it's Revenge
you don't let let an or a terrorist
organization kill a thousand of your
civilians and in monstrous ways and let
them get away with it you have to and
this is the Middle East you have to
understand the mentality of the Middle
East of the Hamas gets away with it
Israel is a goner it's a loser and it
will never be respected and others will
do the same to Israel next week or next
month or next year and the Hamas will do
it again if it still exists you must
crush the Kamas I think this is a
general generally accepted by the
Israeli public today and Netanyahu has
always been a bit of a coward he's
always been afraid to launch um um major
military operations he always talks big
but has never done anything
and that's why the Kamas grew into this
monster which it which has recently
emerged he's also
allowed theah to grow into an even
larger organization than than than the
Hamas um but I think he will have no
choice now but to um um launch this
offensive to destroy the kamash and I
believe in it too I think the Kamas must
be destroyed last night after the
hospital air strike there was protests
in the West Bank and there's been some
skirmishes there over the last week or
two um you previously served in jail
time for not uh for refusing to serve in
the IDF in in in the West Bank and the
occupied territories How concerned are
you about a potential Uprising in the
West Bank and more skirmishes taking
place there as well as in
Gaza there're two different things I
don't anticipate an uprising in the West
Bank I think Israel's
security forces the the shinb the Border
Police the Army um have a sufficient
grip on the West Bank to prevent a
rebellion a massive Rebellion but there
will certainly be clashes as there were
as you say last night after they bought
the Kamas story about what happened at
the hospital yesterday there will be
further clashes uh there the palestin
their Palestinian brothers that is the
West Bank Palestinians Brothers in the
Gaza Strip a are getting a terrible
pounding from the Israeli Air Force
which I think is trying to kill and
destroy Kamas targets but without doubt
is also killing civilians a lot of them
um they feel you know these are their
brothers and they will continue I think
to try to demonstrate against what
Israel will be doing in the coming
months in the Gaza Strip and there will
be clashes and I assume Israel will be
able to suppress any Rebellion
there and Benny you've written before
about the demographic crisis that Israel
potentially faces you written about how
the right-wing religious sexs have many
children compar to the sort of liberal
secular uh
israelies um how do you think that might
play out in the coming
decades as it looks today it looks like
it's going to play out terribly for
Israel for Israeli society and I think
it'll also have an impact on the
Palestinians Israelis have drifted to
the right over the past decades in large
measure this has been a product of
demography it's a matter of the growth
that is the population growth of the SEC
the religious sector in the Jewish
population that means the ultra Orthodox
who are originally were non zionists but
have become more and more a militant and
Zionist and the National Religious
people who started and um basically are
the the um Bedrock of the settlement
Enterprise um they have five six seven
children per family while
secular Israelis liberals um mostly
ashkanazi families have somewhere
between two and three family children
per family and as this if this trend
continues Israel will the the the 20% or
whatever it is of religious 25% 28% of
religious families in Israel will become
30% and 40% moving on to 50% and secular
and liberal Israelis will their numbers
will diminish and this will turn Israel
even more right rightward and um less
able to compromise more
expansionist
[Music]
um it'll be terrible but that's the way
it's going at the moment demographically
is there anything about the state of
Israel that gives you hope for
optimism the only thing which gives me
hope is that the whole Zionist
Enterprise is illogical made little
sense nobody believed from the start or
almost nobody believed in the start that
it could actually achieve statehood or
that Israeli statehood could reach if
you like the Heights in terms of the
internal
creativity science um um prosperity
which is it it it is reached now so a
lot of things have gone against what
common sense says nonetheless they've
happened I'm not saying it's miraculous
but it certainly hasn't followed a
convenient logical pattern the
development of the state of Israel um um
so maybe that's grounds for optimism
that maybe my anticipation or
predictions about um the bad way things
are going are incorrect Maybe
logic will be overcome by something
else we'll see Benny Morris thank you
very much for joining me to my
pleasure